madame la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale peut-être pourrions-nous
émettre un vœu commun en direction du
Premier ministre il est cerné monsieur
le
Président
attention à la multiplication des
texte attention à l'abus des procédures
accélérées
ou à la convocation des commissions
mixtes paritaires en urgence comme en
décembre bien légiféré nécessite temps
et
réflexion permettez-moi de m'adresser
plus spécifiquement à mes collègues
sénatrices et sénateurs et de saluer les
anciens sénateurs nombreux présents ce
soir ici ce qui marque leur attachement
à notre institution
oui maises vux s'adresse à vous vous qui
enrichissez nos débats de vos
interventions et de vos travaux de votre
action sur le terrain en métropole dans
nos outremers et auprès de nos
compatriotes établis de France mais veux
s'adresse à vous mes chers collègues
membres du bureau et de la Conférence
des Présidents avec qui nous partageant
le souci commun de l'institution
sénatoriale mais vux s'adresse aux
commissions et aux délégations qui sont
le carburant de nos travaux mais veux
s'adresse aux présidentes et présidents
de groupes politiques car je le répète
nous sommes une assemblée politique et
c'est quelque chose d'essentiel oui
chacune et chacun d'entre vous
participer à faire du Sénat aujourd'hui
et demain un acteur clé au service de la
démocratie parlementaire car n'oublions
pas que la 5e République est un régime
parlementaire sa pratique le fait
parfois un peu
oublié